[موسيقى]
احييكم واهلا بكم الى نشره التاسعه هذا
المساء تقدمها لكم ميسون ويهد نبدا
بالعناوين
يحضر اوروبا من تجاهل الصين ويؤكد على
اهميتها الاقتصاديه بالنسبه للقاره العجوز
ادانه دوليه لعنف اسرائيل المتصاعد ضد
الفلسطينيين في القدس ودعوات لحكومه
نتانياهو بالتراجع والتهدئه
العام في منهات
فيروس ماربرد يثير قلقا عالميا من تحوله
الى جائحه ودول تحذر مواطنيها من السفر
الى افريقيا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم لطالما شددت اوروبا على ان الصين
لا يمكنها ان تلعب دورا لوقف الحرب في
اوكرانيا لكن نسف هذه الفرضيه ومن اين من
الصين نفسها حين قال انه يمكن لبيكين ان
تلعب دورا رئيسيا لايجاد طريق يؤدي الى
السلام في اوكرانيا مكروه لم يكتفي بهذه
الرساله بل حذر القاره الاوروبيه من تبعات
الابتعاد عن الصين وشدد على اهميتها
الاقتصاديه بالنسبه لاوروبا اما عن زياره
الرئيس الفرنسي ورئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه
الى بيكين فهي تحمل دلالات ادى اهمها ان
مكروه يسعى من خلالها الى الاستمرار
بالدفع باتجاه ولوج افضل الى السوق الصيني
[موسيقى]
زياره الرئيس الفرنسي للصين رفقه رئيسه
المفوضيه الاوروبيه تؤكد ان الهدف يتعدى
العلاقات الفرنسيه الصينيه الضيقه الى
علاقات الاتحاد الاوروبي مع بكين وفي وقت
يطغى ملف اوكرانيا على طاوله المباحثات
الا ان الحوار سيشمل احياء العلاقات على
كل المستويات والاسيام التجاريه منها بعد
قيود كورونا الصارمه خلال جانبين استثمران
كثيره في شراكتهما حيث بلغ اجمالي قيمه
تجاره السلع بين الصين واوروبا
732 مليار دولار عام 2020 بزياده الربع عن
عام 2019
وكانت الصين ثالث اكبر وجهه لصادرات السلع
الاتحاد الاوروبي لكن هي اكبر مصدر
لواردات اوروبا مع نسبه بلغت 22% عام 2021
خبراء اقتصاديون اكدوا ان العلاقه ببساطه
بين الطرفين هي اكبر من ان تفشل وهي لا
ابدا من استراتيجيه الفصل بل التنويع
لكنهم اوضحوا ان اهميه السوق الاوروبيه
كوجهه للصادرات الصينيه تبلغ ضعف اهميه
سوق الصينيه بالنسبه للاوروبيين
تفرقهم السياسه لكن تجمعهما المصالح
الاقتصاديه الاتحاد الاوروبي والصين
يحاولان ايجاد طريق سالكه للشراكه
المستقبليه في غابه دوليه تحكمها الصراعات
والتطاحنات العلاقات الاقتصاديه بين بيكين
وبروكسيل وثيقه رغم نمو تيار داخل الاتحاد
يدعو الى تقليل التعامل معها فقبل حوالي
سنتين تمكنت الصين من تبوء مكانه الشريك
التجاري العالمي الاول الى المنطقه
الاوروبيه خلفا للولايات المتحده
حاملا ملفات السياسه والاقتصاد حل الرئيس
الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون بالصين الى جانب
رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه اورسولا
فونديلاين التي استبقت رحلتها بخطاب اكدت
فيه ان على اوروبا اللجوء الى ادوات
دفاعيه جديده في علاقتها مع التنين
الاسيوي وما تقصده هو وقف تصدير
التكنولوجيا الحساسه الى الصين وتقليل
الاعتماد على الاستيراد منها ما اعتبره
السفير الصيني لدى بروكسل انتهاكا لقواعد
التجاره الدوليه
الرئيس الفرنسي ومن خلال هذه الزياره يسعى
للاستمرار بالدفع باتجاه ولوج افضل الى
السوق الصينيه كما انه لا ينسى السياسه
والحرب في اوكرانيا فحسب
يمكنها ان تؤثر في صنع السلام بسبب قربها
من موسكو لقد اثرت الحرب التي قادتها
روسيا في اوكرانيا بشكل عميق على النظام
الدولي الذي عرفناه منذ عام 19
هذه الحرب انتهكت العديد من مبادئ ميثاق
الامم المتحده والتي يجب علينا الدفاع
عنها بحزم لذا يمكن للصين على وجه التحديد
بسبب علاقاتها الوثيقه مع روسيا ان تلعب
دورا رئيسيا زياره ماكرون
فيه الصراع بين الولايات المتحده والصين
سواء في شان ما تراه واشنطن مسانده صينيه
لروسيا في حرب اوكرانيا او الخلاف بشان
تايوان
فواشنطن تصعد اجراءاتها الاقتصاديه
والتجاريه اتجاه بيكن وتضغط على حلفائها
الاوروبيين للحد من علاقاتهم التجاريه
والاقتصاديه مع الصين لكن منطق المصالح
يجعل هذه العلاقه اقتصاديه اولا واخيرا
بلال الوجداني العربيه
والتزامنا مع وجود الرئيس الفرنسي في
الصين استقبل رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي
كيفن ماكارسي رئيسه
في بدايه اجتماع اثار غضب الصين ويعد هذا
اول اجتماع بين رئيس للتايوان ومسؤول
امريكي رفيع المستوى على الاراضي
الامريكيه منذ عام
وكانت الصين اعترضت بشده على توقف رئيس
التايوان في امريكا واكدت ان ذلك ينتهك
تعهدات الولايات المتحده بالالتزام بسياسه
الصين الواحده
ومتابعه لزياره الرئيس الفرنسي الى الصين
ينضم الى من باريس الباحث الاقتصادي دكتور
دانيال ملحم دكتور ملحم اهلا بكم معنا زار
اليوم الرئيس الفرنسي الصين ولكن كان
برفقته وبصحبته العشرات من مدراء الشركات
في فرنسا
وخبراء اقتصاديين ما هي دلاله هذا الكم
الكبير من الاقتصاديين مع الرئيس ماكرون
واهميه هذه الزياره بالنسبه لفرنسا على
الصعيد الاقتصادي
تحيه لك سيدتي والمشاهدين الكرام بالاحرى
هي اهميه لاوروبا بالدرجه الاولى ولفرنسا
بالدرجه الثانيه على اعتبار ان الرئيس
ماكرون هو حامل الشعار الاتحاد الاوروبي
وهو الاسحاربه الاتحاد الاوروبي وبالتالي
حتى وجود المفوضيه الاوروبيه
معه يعطي اكثر
وصف اوروبي اكثر ما هو فرنسي وبالتالي
الدرجه الاولى هو سيكون اوروبي اليوم هناك
رساله واضحه جدا ان الصين هي شريك
استراتيجي لاوروبا بالدرجه الاولى لماذا
لانه مليان اليوم نحن ان هناك ثلاثه
مراكز جيو اقتصاديه موجوده اليوم الولايات
المتحده الصين واوروبا الولايات المتحده
منذ 2015 مع الرئيس ترامب تحولت نحو
الاقتصاد الداخلي وبدات تحفيز الاقتصاد
اقتصادها عن طريق طلب الداخلي الصين حاولت
لفتره طويله عمليا منذ 2016 ولكن لم تنجح
الى الان بتحويل اقتصادها لتحفيز اقتصادي
الطلب الداخلي اوروبا لا تزال الى اليوم
نتيجه المشاكل الداخليه هي تعتمد على
تحفيز اقتصادها الطلب الخارجي عمليا ايات
الحركه التجاريه الاستيراد والتصدير
واليوم الشريك الوحيد الموجود
بالنسبه لاوروبا والحاجه الاستراتيجيه
بالنسباوبا هي الصين لذلك من خلال
اوروبا وفرنسا بحاجه اكثر
للصين ما زالت الصين هي بحاجه اكثر لهذا
الاوروبي
الاثنين سيدتي لماذا لان الصين اليوم فشلت
الى الان بتحويل اقتصادها الى الطلب
الداخلي وتحويل اقتصاد الخدمات وبالتالي
هي بحاجه لتحفيز للصادرات وغيره وخاصه
ايضا هناك الكثير من التكنولوجيا التي لا
تتسال بحاجه لها الصين وذلك والاستثمارات
التي شهدناه خلال سنتين الاخرين في قطاعات
الاشباه الموصلات في اوروبا او الطاقه
البديله والتكنولوجيا الطاقه البديله
وتكنولوجيا البطاريات لا تزال الصين بحاجه
لها بشكل كبير وهي بحاجه لها من اوروبا
صعوبه الحصول عليهم العملات المتحده
الامريكيه فالمقابل الاوروبا وخاصه
المانيا هي بحاجه الى اسواق عمليا لتصريف
منتجته وتصريف صناعاتها واليوم يتخذ
الرئيس ماكرون معه الكثير من هذا صحيح من
الشركات ولكن عينه على اعاده التوازن
للميزان التجاري وخاصه هناك القطاع
الزراعي هناك النمو 20% بالطلب على
المنتجات الزراعيه في الصين وبالتالي
اوروبا تستهدف اعتبار رائده في هذا المجال
وتستهدف هذا المجال اضافه لذلك بعض
القطاعات النوويه
وتحفيز الاستثمار في اوروبا اليوم المشكله
الرئيسيه في
شارع الاوروبي يعني نحن نعلم بانه
العلاقات التجاريه
مشحونه بشكل متزايد مع الاتحاد الاوروبي
والصين هل سيستطيع في هذه الزياره الرئيس
ماكرون من تحسين هذه العلاقات
هذا ما نامله ولكن
ما نراه عمليا المؤشرات الاقتصاديه منذ
2016 اليوم هي في تراجع مستمر الاستثمارات
الصينيه في اوروبا هي في تراجع حتى تصميم
بدات تعتمد بشكل اقل على الواردات من
اوروبا لا تزال تعتمد بشكل رئيسي على على
المانيا ولكن من امله اعاده تحسين خلال
فتره الانتقاليه المقبله ما بين الخمسين
الى سبع سنوات المقبله ولكن بتقديري انا
اليوم الرئيس الفرنسي في موقف صعب سياسي
لماذا لانه عمليا عندما تذهب اوروبا موحده
يتم الحديث بشيء ما ولكن اليوم ذهب الرئيس
الالماني المستشار الالماني لوحدها وذهبت
اسبانيا لوحدها واليوم الرئيس الفرنسي
لوحده وبالتالي تستطيع الصين اللعب على
هذه التناقضات واليوم
مع الرئيس الفرنسي اليست رساله للصين
بانها لا تستطيع اللعب على كل هذه الاحبال
وبان اوروبا موحده
بايجاز لو سمحت
اليوم اليوم الصين نتعلم جيدا ان اوروبا
ليست موحده عندما طلبت وهي تعلم جيدا
عندما طلب الرئيس ماكرون مواكبه ارنستشار
الالماني الى الصين رفض المستشار الالماني
وبالتالي هي تعرف هذه التفاصيل اليوم
المفوضيه الاوروبيه موجوده بشكل سوري مع
الرئيس ماكرون وبالتالي لا اعتقد انه سوف
يتم
نتائج كبيره عن هذه الزياره اعتقد سوف
تكون نتائجها محدوده ببعض الاستثمارات
التي تعتبر حاجه استراتيجيه للصين
وتساعد عمليا بتدفقات الاستثمارات نحو
اوروبا واعاده توازن بشكل طفيف الى
الميزان التجاري هذا ما نامله على المدى
القصير شكرا
لك دكتور دانيال ملحم على هذه المشاركه
معنا في التاسعه هذا المساء
قال الرئيس الروسي بلازمي بوتين ان هناك
ما يدعو للاعتقاد بان اجهزه مخابرات غربيه
ضالعه فيما وصفه باعمال تخريبيه وارهابيه
نفذتها اوكرانيا في روسيا وفي اجتماعه مع
مجلس الامن الروسي اتهم بوتين اوكرانيا
بارتكاب جرائم ضد مسؤولين روس وجنود في
قوات الامن وصحفيين ومدرسين بمساعده اجهزه
المخابرات الغربيه
النازيون الجدد والمتعاونون معهم لا
يعملون فقط في المناطق المنضمه حديثا
للاتحاد الروسي ولكن ايضا يرتكبون جرائم
في مناطق اخرى وتوجد العديد من الاشارات
على مشاركه مخابرات غربيه في التحضير لهذه
الهجمات التخريبيه
نقله وكاله توتاس الروسيه عن اجهزه
الطوارئ في العاصمه موسكو ان حريقه اندلع
في مبنى تابع لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه في
وسط موسكو بالقرب من الكريم للمساء
الاربعاء
قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه في ختام
اجتماعات وزراء خارجيه الناتوسيل قال ان
بوتين يعاني من انتكاسات في حربه
باوكرانيا ولذلك يقصف المدنيين ويعمل على
رفع اسعار الطاقه
مهتمون بمنطقه المحيطين الهندي والهادي
ونرحب بمشاركه اليابان واستراليا
واليوزيلندا وكوريا في قمه حلف الناتو
المقبله والحلف اليوم اقوى واكثر ارتفاعا
من اي وقت مضى وسنقدم مساعدات لاوكرانيا
تسمح لها بحمايه مدنيين من هجمات المسيرات
بوتين فشل في تحقيق اهدافه في اوكرانيا
ويعاني من انتكاسات بحربه هناك لذلك يعمل
على رفع اسعار الطاقه وموسكو تستخدم
احتياطيا مالي بسبب العقوبات
اكدت المجرى انها لن تدعم قرارات حلف
الناتو التي يمكن ان تؤدي الى صراع مع
روسيا بحسب وزير خارجيه المجر
ان عدم تورط الناتو في الحرب باوكرانيا هو
اساسي ويجب منع نشوب صراع مباشر بين
الناتو وروسيا
اعلن الرئيس البولنديه ان جدود استعداد
بلاده لتسليم كل مقاتلاتها من طراز 29 الى
اوكرانيا مستقبلا واضاف خلال مؤتمر صحفي
مع نظيره الاوكراني ان بولندا
ليرتفع الاجمالي الى اربعه عشر وقريبا
ستكون مستعده لتسليم كل اسطولها من هذه
المقاتلات الذي يضم 30 طائره لاوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
تم ارسالها للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه في
الاشهر الاخيره اربع طائرات ميج اخرى تم
ارسالها مؤخرا هذا يعني ان الاجماليه
ثمانيه نحن مستعدون وكنت اتحدث مع الرئيس
بشان ذلك اليوم مستعدون لتسليم ست طائرات
اخرى ويتم تجهيزها الان لذا نعتقد انه من
الممكن ان يكون التسليم في المستقبل
القريب
نذهب الان الى البيت الابيض وهذا الصحفي
مع المتحدثه
الكارين جانبير
سؤال اخر حول نفس الموضوع حلتي كيف كانت
ردود افعل الرئيس بشان التهم الموجهه
لترامب تعنينا يوم الامس الرئيس
وكما
ذكرت كان قد تحدث الى الشعب الامريكي وهذا
سوف يكون محطه اهتمامه وعلى حال ما جرى في
الاسبوع الماضي
كنا قد سمعنا بلائحه الاتهام وقد تم
اطلاعهم من قبل فريقه وموظفيه حول هذا
الامر وكلنا علمنا من خلال التقارير
الاعلاميه هذا كل ما لدينا بالنسبه
للاجتماع حول
الرئيس رئيس التايوان
واجتماعها مع سيد مكار به هل هناك اي حديث
عن تمارين عسكريه قد تجري بين الولايات
المتحده دعوني اكرر مقاله الوزير بلينكل
لعلكم سمعتموه في اكثر من المناسبه
ما ذكره في اجتماع وزراء النيتو في بروكسل
كنا واضحين في هذا الشان فقد قلنا بانه ما
من سبب يدفع لبيجين
لتحويل هذا المضيق لاستخدامه كدريعه
لابداء اي ردود افعال ممكنه كنا واضحين
بان هذا المضيق هو مهم
وعلاقتنا مع
تايلاند علاقتنا مع تايوان هي علاقه عريقه
وقديمه وما من سبب يدفع الصين لتبدي اي
ردود افعال غريبه سؤال اخر
لقد
قد يقوم الرئيس باجراء رحله في الفتره
القادمه
مع من سوف يستعمل لا اعلم اذا ما كانت سوف
من سوف يكون بصحبه الرئيس في رحلته من سوف
يكون من افراد اسرته
دعوني اعطيكم
بعض المعلومات التي قد تتضح خلال الايام
القليله القادمه
لقد تم اجراء حديثا مع الرئيس سوف يتوجه
لزياره الى المملكه المتحده وايرلندا
هاتان البلدان اللتان تجمعنا علاقه قويه
فيها بما في ذلك زياره بلفاست وكانتيو
لكن كما اسلفت الحديث انه يتطلع الى هذه
الزياره وسوف سوف سوف
يسلط الضوء على ان اسرته تشاطر تاريخا
كبيرا مع ايرلندا ونحن المهاجرون
الايرلنديون كنا قد شاطرنا هذه العلاقات
التي
ترتكز على الصداقه التي تجمع بلدينا وفي
هذا السياق سوف تكون هذه الرحله مهمه
لاسرته بالاضافه الى ذلك هناك الجاليه
الايرلنديه الامريكيه التي سوف تنظر الى
كيفيه تشكيل هذه البلاد لذا فان الرئيس
يتطلع الى هذه الرحله
هل
ما استطيع ان اقوله وهذا ما عكفنا على
تكراره منذ اشهر اننا نعتقد
انه
قد قد قمل الكونجرس بالتعاطي مع هذه
المساله من قبل الحزبين بطريقه منفصله
وكان هناك توجه لرفع عقوبه الاعدام
من الدستور
وانه ما من مفاوضات بان قد نجريها بشان
هذا الموضوع لانها مساله
قد يجدر بالكونجرس ان يتداول بشكل
الان سنتحدث مشاهدينا عن الحاجه الفنلنديه
لدخول حلف شمال الاطلسي بانها ليست احاديه
الجانب بل طبعا هي متبادله المنافع
للطرفين اذا انضمام فنلندا للنيتو يضيف
للاخير جيشا قويا ويضاعف طول حدوده مع
روسيا وبالتالي طبعا يساهم بتعزيز
الدفاعات جناحه الشرقي في مواجهه اي هجوم
روسيه هل سينكي تمتلك جيشا كبيرا بالنسبه
لعدد سكانها وحجمها في اوروبا فما يقرب من
ثلث السكان البالغين فيها هم من جنود
الاحتياط هي قادره على حشد 280 الف جندي
في زمن الحرب والاعتماد على احتياطيه يبلغ
بالاجمال 870 الف جنديا فهي من الدول
الاوروبيه القليله التي ابقت على نموذج
التجنيد الاجباري كما ايضا تمتلك واحده من
افضل ترسانات المدفعيه في اوروبا مع 1500
قطعه مدفعيه ضخمه وذاتيه الحركه فيما
قوتها الجويه ايضا تقوم بالاساس على نحو
خمس وخمسين طائره اف18 الامريكيه الصنع مع
التعاقد على شراء 64 طائره من طراز اف 35
اضافه طبعا الى كل هذه القدرات العسكريه
من شان فنلندا توفير مزايا جغرافيه رئيسيه
تعزز دفاعات الناتو فحدود فنلندا مع روسيا
تمتد لاكثر من
1280 كيلومترا وستساهم بتقريب الحلف اكثر
الى شبه جزيره كولا الروسيه علما بان كولا
هي ارض استراتيجيه تقع على بعد
177 كيلو مترا شرق الحدود وهناك تحتفظ
روسيا بغواصات الصواريخ الباليستيه وايضا
الرؤوس الحربيه النوويه واي ضا يتمركز
الاسطول الشمالي اذا انضمام فنلندا الى
النيتو وربما السويد لاحقا قد يغير المشهد
العسكري من البلطيق الى القطب الشمالي اذا
لدينا قوه ردع للحلف يقابلها مخاوف من
التصعيد مع روسيا التي تشكل اراضيها اكثر
من 50% من ساحل المحيط المتجمد الشمالي
[موسيقى]
ميدانيا في الحرب الاوكرانيه اقر الرئيس
الاوكرانيه
الانسحاب من مدينه قائلا ان الاهم هو عدم
خساره الجيش ولا يجب فقدان افراد بسبب
الحصار لكنه اضاف ان شحنات الذخيره من
حلفاء اوكرانيا ستعزز الدفاعات العسكريه
وسيستطيعون المحاربه بشكل اسرع ليس في
باخد فحسب بل في جميع الاراضي الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]
عبر البيت الابيض عن قلقه من تطورات
الاحداث في المسجد الاقصى واشدد على ضروره
خفض التصعيد بين الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين بدوره اعرب الامين العام
للامم المتحده انطونيو عن صدمته وذهوله
ازاء مستوى العنف الذي استخدمته قواته
الامن الاسرائيليه بحق مصلين فلسطينيين
داخل المسجد الاقصى وقال ستيفان دو جاريك
المتحدث ان الامين العام شاهد صور العنف
والضرب داخل الموقع المقدس ووصف الوضع
بالمحزن والماساوي
قبل ذلك عبرت جامعه الدول العربيه عن
ادانتها الشديده للاعتداء الاسرائيلي بحق
المصلين العزال في المسجد الاقصى وحملت
الجامعه في بيان صادر عن اجتماع مجلسها
على مستوى المندوبين اسرائيل مسؤوليه ما
ينتج عن اجراءاتها التي تقود حريه العباده
في المقدسات بمدينه القدس من جهته اكد
المغرب ضروره احترام الوضع القانوني
والديني والتاريخي في القدس والابتعاد عن
الممارسات والانتهاكات التي من شانها
القضاء على كل فرص السلام بالمنطقه وادانت
كل من السعوديه ومصر والاردن اقتحام
المسجد الاقصى والاعتداء على المصلين
المعتكفين كما عبرت المانيا وبريطانيا عن
القلق الشديد تجاه التصعيد في المسجد
الاقصى
في التاسعه هذا المساء نتابع بعد قليل
الامم المتحده تدعو طالبان الى تراجع عن
قرار منع النساء الافغانيات من العمل
[موسيقى]
جوله قضائيه فاز بها الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب في حربه ضد الممثله
ستورميدانيا هذه الجوله لن تكن في
كاليفورنيا حيث قضت محكمه الاستئناف في
الولايه بان تدفع دانييلز مبلغا 120 الف
دولار اضافيه لترامب لقاء اتعاب المحاماه
في دعوه تشيير التي اقامتها ضده وخسرتها
ترامب والجمهوريون استمروا بتوعد مدعي
عاما هاتا بالرد والانتقام اذ قال الرئيس
لجنه الرقابه في مجلس النواب الامريكي
الجمهوريه ان المجلس سيمضي قدما في تحقيق
مع مدعي عامه
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا نتوقف مع هذه الصور لحريق في احد
الاسواق في اربيل اذا هذه الصور اتتنا منذ
قليل لحريق اندلع في احد الاسواق في اربيل
يبدو من خلال هذه الصور بان الحريق كبير
دعونا نستمع الى صوت الطبيعي
[تصفيق]
نعود مشاهدينا الى موضوع ترامب ولائحه
الاتهام الطويله التي فاقت بنودها
الثلاثين بندا طبعا واجهها الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب لكن غابت
عنها ما وصفت بالجريمه الثانيه صحيفه وولز
مفقودات في لائحه الاتهامات 34 هذه لكي
تكون التهم جنائيه يحتاج المدعي العام الى
جريمه من نوع اخر فاين هي هذه الجريمه
الاخرى براجيا يزعم ان ترامب زور مرارا
سجلات تجاريه من الدرجه الاولى واخفى
معلومات عن جمهور الناخبين خلال
الانتخابات الرئاسيه لعام 2016 فيما تهمل
ابرز كانت شراء صوت بل صمت ممثله اباحيه ب
130 الف دولار دفعها مايكل كوهان مساعده
ترامب السابق هنا ادعاء
بان ترامب انتهك قوانين تمويل الحملات
الانتخابيه اسقط طبعا باعتراف كهان بما
قام به وبحسب عضو سابق في لجنه الانتخابات
الفيدراليه ان الاموال المدفوعه
لا تشكل نفقات حمله انتخابيه جميع هذه
التهم هي فرديه وتزوير السجلات التجاريه
يعد جنحه في نيويورك وليس جنايه فما هي
الجريمه الاخرى التي يزعم ان ترامب يحاول
التستر عليها
لم اكن اتخيل للحظه ان هذا سيحصل في
الولايات المتحده
الحزب الجمهوري وقف متحدا خلف ترامب في
هذه القضيه واللافته كان تصريحا
الجمهوري اللدودي لترامب الذي اعتبر ان
القضاء يستعمل تهما جنائيه من اجل التوافق
مع اجنده سياسيه ولكن يبقى صمت الزعيم
الجمهوري متماك المدويا في ارجاء المشهد
خاصه مع طلب ترامب من الجمهوريين وقفه
تمويل وزاره العدل ومكتب التحقيقات
الفيدرالي من الكونجرس
لا اعتقد ان زعماء الجمهوريين سيذهبون الى
مواجهه مباشره مع وزاره العدل كما طلبت
ترامب وسبب المباشر ان معظمهم سياخذون
الانتخابات المقبله ولديهم في برنامجهم
ملفات الجريمه وامن الحدود وغيرها ولا
يريدون تعقيدات تمنع اعاده انتخابهم
وسيستكملون تحقيقاتهم ودعم ترامب ولكن ضمن
حدود معقوله
ترامب يحاول الان توجيه الاعين على القضيه
من منظار قضائي بحث معتبرا ان التهم التي
وجهت له غير قانونيه وغير دستوريه
الان المسار الذي اتبعه المدعي العام في
نيويورك في توجيه هذه الاتهامات كله صحيح
ولكن يمكن ان يلعب الفريق القانوني للرئيس
السابق على عده نقاط مفصليه يمكن ان تشكل
مخرجا ان كان من ناحيه التقادم وسقوط
المهله القانونيه او حتى التاثير المباشر
في قضايا مختلفه
التفاصيل القانونيه كثيره ويمكن ان تشكل
فخا موقوتا للرئيس الاكثر جدلا في
الولايات المتحده وتؤثر بشكل مباشر على
مسار الانتخابات المحموم العمل المقبل
ريتا سليمان العربيه واشنطن
ولنعرف المزيد وليعطينا صوره واضحه جدا
عما يجري في قضايا ترامب ينضم الى من
واشنطن
يبدو بانه ترامب اليوم حقق انتصار في
كاليفورنيا ماذا لدينا من تفاصيل حول هذه
هذا الانتصار حيث حمله ترامب ومناصريه
يسموه اليوم انتصار
من المفارقات ان الممثله الاباحيه اتهمت
رئيس الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بانه
يشوه سمعتها كان هذا في العام 2018 ورفت
عليه قضيه وقالت ان الرئيس الامريكي عندما
قال انها تقوم بعمليه نصب ضده هذا اساءه
سمعه للممثله الاباحيه المحكمه في
كاليفورنيا قررت ان من حق الرئيس الامريكي
ان يعبر عن رايه وهو لما يقل اشياء لا
يسمح بها القانون واعادت رفع القضيه مره
ثانيه وجربتها او بالاحرى جازتها هذه
المحكمه للمره الثالثه بدفاعتك ليف
المحاكمات هذه قضيه تبقى انتصار للرئيس
ترامب ولفريقه القانون في كاليفورنيا ولكن
كما ذكرت انت قبل قليل انها منفصله عن
القضيه في نيويورك ولكن اقلهبير هل تؤثر
يعني الى اي حد تعطي زخما للرئيس ترامب
بان يبقى على تمسكه بانه بريء وبان ما
يحصل معه هو اضطهاد سياسي
اي انتصار للترامب هو انتصار كبير ولكنه
يواجه تحديات كثيره في قضيه نيويورك
والاكثر من ذلك ما يواجهه في قضايا جورجيا
وقضايا تحقيق وزاره العدل في الهجوم على
الكونجرس وايضا في قضيه التحقيق في
الملفات ملفات الاستخبارات التي وجدت في
منزله الرئيس الامريكي يريد ان يصور كل
هذه القضيه على انها اعتداء عليه وبالتالي
يسلط الاضواء على نفسه ويتابع عمليه
الانتباه وهذا يعطيه الكثير من الشعبيه في
صفوف الجمهوريه بالنسبه لهذا التصعيد
المستمر منذ بدايه هذه القضيه ما مدعي
عاما هاتن وبين بين رئيس ترامب
والجمهوريين من جهه على مدعي عامه وعلى
الديمقراطيين بشكل عام بانهم يستغلون هذه
القضيه ماذا نتوقع هل سيبقى هذا التصعيد
وماذا سيكون سقفه ونهايته
في بعض التفاصيل من ما حدث في داخل
المحكمه يوم امس هو ان القاضي وجهها
ملاحظه لمحاميه ترامب بحضور ترامب من انه
لا يجب ان يهدد بالعنف ويتحدث بكلام كبير
بين مزدوجين حول القاضي والمحكمه والمدعي
العام وغير ذلك ولكن الرئيس السابق توجه
من يورج مباشره الى فلوريدا
هجوبا لاذعا مره اخرى على القاضي وزوجته
وابنته وعلى المدعي العام ايضا الرئيس
ترامب بحاجه للاستمرار في هذه الحمله لانه
يرى انه من الضروري ان يصور ان
الديمقراطيين يستعملون العداله ضده
بالعمليه السياسيه بالامس مثل ترامب في
منهات في محكمه منهتن انما الاجراءات
التاليه الان متى نتوقع ان تكون وما هي
طبيعتها
يستطيع الرئيس ترامب ان يطالب بشكل رمز
رسمي بان ينقل هذه المحاكمه لو حصلت من
منهات الى مكان اخر وهو تحدث عن هذا
الموضوع اكثر من مره نحن لا ننتظر ان يكون
هناك اي جلسات للمحاكمه في نيويورك قبل
عده اشهر وربما نتحدث هنا عن الخريف وانت
تستمر هذه المحاكمه حتى العام 2024 اي
خلال الحمله الانتخابيه الرئازيه هناك
قضايا اخرى سوف تدخل ايضا على المسار
القضائي وسوف نرى الكثير من الانتخابات
والمحاكمه شكرا لك من واشنطن بارغام مراسل
العربيه على كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل
[موسيقى]
يعني لم يغب كورونا حتى بدانا نقلق من
فيروس جديد وهو ماربر هذا القلق المتزايد
يغذيه مشاهدينا تفشي هذا الفيروس فيروس في
تنزانيا وغينيا الاستوائيه في مشهد طبعا
شبهه خبراء باعاده تجربه كورونا الكارثيه
فالهاجس من اتساع رقعه الفيروس وتحوله الى
جائحه عالميه بدا بالانتشار وما يسحبه من
عزل محتمل لدول شرق وغرب افريقيا منظمه
الصحه العالميه حذرت من تفشي الفيروس
بالدولتين الافريقيتين اللتين سجلتا ثماني
الى ثلاثه عشره اصابه في كل دوله معظمهم
طبعا لقوا حتفهم للاسف وعلى اثره بدا
الدول العالم باتخاذ اجراءات السلامه
والاحتياطات اللازمه دول الخليجيه منعت
رعاياها من السفر الى هاتين الدولتين فيما
اكتفت بل اكتفت دول اخرى بالتحذير هو من
عائله الفيروس المسبب لحمى ايبولا النسفيه
هو طبعا شديد العدوى يتسبب بارتفاع
الحراره والصداع الحاد والالام العضليه
ومعدلات وفيات عاليه بين المصابين اما طرق
انتقاله فهي كالتالي ينتقل للبشر من
خفافيش الفاكهه وايضا من الاتصال المباشر
بالسوائل الجسديه للمصابين والاسطح
والمواد الملوثه بتلك الوسائل بل السوائل
بعد كورونا فيروس ماربرد يثير الرعب في
العالم
اعراض فيروس ماربرج الصداع والحمى والم
العضلات بعدها يعاني المصاب من اسهال
والام في المعده وغثيان وطفح جلدي معدلات
الوفيات بفيروس تتراوح بين
24% الى
88% يموت المصاب بعد ثمانيه الى تسعه ايام
بسبب النزيف الحاد والصدمه فيروس شديد
العدوى من عائله فيروس ايبولا الفتاك مصاب
ماربرج يظهر المصاب بملامح شبحيه عينان
عميقتان ووجه بلا ملامح فيروس ومربرج هل
من علاج حتى اللحظه لا يوجد علاج او لقاح
محدد للفيروس
عبر من دكتور احمد سلمان استاذ علم
المناعه وتطهير اللقاحات في معهد ادوارد
دكتور اهلا بكم معنا ما هي نسبه ان يتحول
تفشي الى جائحه كالتي حصلت مع كورونا
اهلا وسهلا وتحياتي لحضرتك والساده
المشاهدين واسعد الله مساءكم بكل خير هو
الفيروس او عائله يعني فيروسات الايبولا
هي موجوده بالفعل يعني من اكثر من حوالي
سبعين عام وحدث بالفعل تفشيات كثيره جدا
قبل ذلك بتكون محدوده في الغالب داخل
افريقيا لكن مؤخرا ابتدا يحدث بعض
الانتشارات خارج نطاق افريقيا نتيجه طبعا
يعني سهوله التحرك بين
والسفر والانتقال بين الدول لكن بيضل
لدينا انتقاله محدود يعني مقارنه
بالفيروسات التنفسيه طبعا زي
فيروس كورونا المستجده والانفلونزا لانه
لابد من يعني انتقال السوائل الجسديه
بصوره مباشره سواء عن طريق انتقالها عن
عاقل مثل الخفافيش مثلا او المريض بذات
نفسه سوائل الجسديه سواء الدم اللعاب
الافرازات خلال العلاقه الجنسيه وبالتالي
في الغالب عندما ينتقل
التفشي يكون داخل اسره او داخل منزل واحد
ومنها يبدا في الانتقال
من حديثك الان بانه هذه المره حقيقه لا
داعي للهلاله لانه في بدايه كورونا قالوا
لا داعي للهلع وراينا بان هذه الجائحه
يعني
كلفتنا الكثير خلال سنتين هل حقيقه لا
داعي للخوف لا داعي للهلع هذه المره
اكيد لا داعي للهلع مهم جدا متابعه طبعا
التطورات
حتى الان لا يوجد ما يشير على انه هناك
مثلا تحور او تغول في الفيروس هو فقط يعني
الانتشار الموجود نتيجه مثلا الاكتضاض او
الاستحام او الكلام ده لكن بتظل الحالات
في محيط محدود جدا نتيجه ضروره انتقال
السوائل الجسديه
لقاح لهذا الفيروس لماذا حتى الان ليس
هناك من علاج نهائي لهذا الفيروس او حتى
لقاح مع العلم 77 سنه ده سؤال مهم جدا هو
بس في نقطه قبل ان نتكلم في اللقاح فكره
انه في الغالب الشخص بيكون معدي بعد ظهور
الاعراض وده شيء ايضا مهم جدا ان الشخص
بتظهر عليه بعض البثور او بيكون يعني
احساسه بحاله المرض والتعب والحمى بتكون
ظهرت وبعدها يكون معدي وده ايضا شيء بيقلل
من حده الانتشار مقارنه بكورونا مثلا ان
انت بتكون ممكن لا اعراض لديك وتكون نقل
للمرض بالنسبه للعلاجات واللقاحات هو
بالفعل يعني ليس تحديدا ولكن
لكنه حتى من من حوالي ثلاثه سنوات او اربع
سنوات كانت منظمه الصحه العالميه وضعته
على قائمه الفيروسات الاكثر خطوره او يعني
متوقع خطورتها وانتشارها
لانها يعني نسبه وفياتها تحديدا عاليه جدا
وبالتالي كان مثلا حتى الان الان هناك
لقاح معتمد للابولا لانه اخذ الاهتمام
والبحث العلمي والتطوير وانتهى من تجاربه
وبالفعل هناك
معروف بان هذا الفيروس قاتل والوفيات
عاليه جدا ولكن ما هي الرعايه الصحيه
للناس في ظل عدم وجود علاج له بايجاز لو
سمحت
هناك علاج لتخفيض حده الانتكاس المناعه
لانه ما يؤدي للوفاه في الغالب هي الحمى
النزيفيه نتيجه رده فعل مناعه عنيفه ولكن
للاسف فعاليته ليست عاليه جدا اللقاحات
هناك العديد منها في التجارب السريريه لكن
لابد من الدعم لها حتى يتم انتهائها ويعني
اعتماد هذه اللقاحات ولكن بالفعل هناك
العديد من اللقاحات منذ ان اعلنت بنظاره
الصحه العالميه ضروره عمل اللقاحات وتم
يعني توجيه الانتباه والدعم الحقيقي
للباحثين لانتاج وده حدث عندما تم عمل ذلك
بالنسبه
للدكتور احمد سلمان استاذ علم المناعه
وتطوير اللقاحات في معهد ادوارد
[موسيقى]
اذان الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
من اعطالبان النساء من العمل لصالح
المنظمه الدوليه في البلاد واكدت الامم
المتحده ان قرار منع عمل النساء سيؤذي
الملايين من الافغان الذين هم في حاجه
ماسه للمساعدات كما طالب غوتيري السلطات
طالبان بالتراجع عن القرار فورا واتخاذ
اجراءات لحمايه حقوق النساء والاطفال
اعترض وزير الخارجيه مولود شاوج اوغلو على
الاجتماع الذي عقده السفير الامريكي جيف
فليك مع مرشح المعارضه الرئيسي للرئاسه
كمالك لجدار اوغلو وصفها اياه بغير
المقبوله وشددات شاوش اوغلو على ان اجتماع
سفير يتعارض مع الممارسه الدبلوماسيه في
الوقت الذي تواجه فيه تركيا انتخابات في
اقل من شهرين
في نشرتنا سنتابع بعد قليل
يعني الفرحه والمشاعر جياشه يعني سعداء
جدا مسرورين واستقبلونا حتى بدايه المطاف
الرحلات بين اربيل وجده
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنا وزير الداخليه
الفرنسيه جلال درامانو ان خطر الارهابي في
فرنسا مرتفع للغايه واضاف درامانان انه تم
احباطه 41 هجوما ارهابيا منذ عام 2017
واحوالي عشر هجمات منذ عام 2020 مشيرا الى
ان هذا التهديد ياتي من جماعات متطرفه من
الجيولوجيات مختلفه
وعلى صعيد الاحتجاجات توعدت النقابات
الفرنسيه بعد انتهاء لقاء ممثليها برئيسه
الوزراء اليزابيث بمواصله معركتها ضد
قانون اصلاح نظام التقاعد حيث قال ممثلها
ان اللقاء لم يكن مثمرا ولم تظهر رئيسه
الوزراء اي انفتاح او تعاون بخصوص القانون
المثير للجدل الذي طرح تململا واضطرابات
في الشارع الفرنسي وجاء هذا في وقت توجه
فيه الرئيس الفرنسي الى الصين لبحث تعزيز
العلاقات الاقتصاديه بين البلدين ومناقشه
الوضع في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
رسائل عده حملتها القاذفه الامريكيه التي
حلقت فوق اجواء شبه الجزيره الكوريه
استعداد للرد بسرعه وبشكل ساحق على اي
استفزاز كوري شماليه قاذفه باثنين وخمسين
المصممه لحمل اسلحه نوويه رافقتها مقاتلات
امريكيه وكوريه جنوبيه في تدريب المشترك
رغم شذبي لمثل هذه المناورات ووصفها بانها
معاديه فما هي هذه القاذفات التي ارسلتها
واشنطن عبر المجال الجوي الكوري الجنوبيه
قاذفات
52 هي عنصر اساسي في قوه سلاح الجو
الامريكي قامت بمئات الطلعات الاستراتيجيه
خلال حرب فيتنام واسقطت اكثر من 15 طنا من
القنابل ابرز مميزاتها قدرتها على الطيران
بحموله كبيره من الق الدخائر كما شاهدنا
منذ قليل تبلغ 35 طنا وتمتلك مدى تشغيليا
يزيد عن 14 الف كيلو متر بدون اعاده
التزود بالوقود الجويه هي ايضا قادره على
حمله صواريخ رؤوس نوويه وصواريخ باليستيه
لقصف اهداف من مسافه مئات الكيلومترات ان
قاذفه باثنين وخمسين تمثل مزيجا من
التكنولوجيا الحديثه وايضا القديمه ويبلغ
عمرها الافتراضي نحو 30 عاما
[موسيقى]
تواصلوا القطاعات الصحيه في السعوديه
تقديم خدماتها الطبيه في علاج واسعاف
المرضى من المعتمرين والزوار في المسجد
الحرام على مدار الساعه اذ اعلنت اكثر من
عشر مستشفيات واثنين مركزا صحيا
جاهزتها لخدمه ضيوف الرحمن في شهر رمضان
وتونس السعوديه طبعا اهتماما بالغا بقطاع
الصحه وتسعى لتقديم خدمات صحيه ذات جوده
عاليه لكل من المواطنين والمقيمين وعلى
وجه الخصوص ضيوف الرحمن في من المعتمرين
في شهر رمضان
ينضم الينا مكه المكرمه اسامه القاسم وراس
العربيه ومن المدينه المنوره سلطان
السلالمي مراسل العربيه ايضا اهلا بكما
ابدا معك اسامه بالنسبه لبيان الرئاسه
الخاص بالتزاحم ماذا يمكن ان تعطينا من
تفاصيل
[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا ميسون تحيه طيبه ملك ولجميع
مشاهدي قناه العربيه انقل لكم الصوت
والصوره اليوم من ساحات الحرم المكي
الشريف وانقل لكم ايضا الان نستعرض لكم
هذه اللقطات عند باب الملك عبد العزيز
اشهر الابواب الموجوده هنا في الحرم المكي
الشريف والتي يدخل من خلالها الزوار
والمعتمر طبعا الرئاسه اصدرت في بيان تنبه
فيه على الزوار من المعتمرين باهميه
الابتعاد عن مواطن الازدحام المتواجده في
الحرم المكي نشهد الان ايضا صلاه التراويح
في الحرم المكي ونشاهد هذه الزحام
المتواجده على ساحات المسجد الحرام طبعا
بالتاكيد اليوم حنا نتكلم عن خطه تشغيليه
محكمه بدات بالعرش الاولى والنت الرئاسه
عن اكتمالها وايضا بدانا في الخطه
التشغيليه الثانيه التي نشهد اليوم يومها
الرابع من خلال عده ايام تشمل 10 ايام لكل
خطه هذه الخطه تشمل خطه متوازنه للحد من
الازدحام والابتعاد عن مواطن الازدحام
طبعا كما نشاهد الان هناك مداخل
ومواطن اخرى ايضا
للخروج وهي بالتاكيد محميه من خلال الجهات
الامنيه المسانده والمشاركه في الحرم
المكي الشريف طبعا بالتاكيد احنا نتكلم
اليوم عن وصول الزوار والمعتمرين الى
حوالي 13 مليون زائر ومعتمر ما يعني ان
الخطه تمشي بشكل صحيح طبعا بالايام
القادمه سنشهد ايضا ازدحاما اكبر من خلال
عدد الزوار والمعتمرين هذه الاستحامات
التي نشاهدها الان هي تقريبا ازدحامات
التي تبدا من العصر الى اخر الليل بهذه
الطريق واحيانا تزيد نسبه نسبه الازدحام
طبعا ميسون احنا نتكلم اليوم ايضا عن وجود
عدد من المستشفيات الموجوده مستشفى اجياد
وايضا مستشفى رحله الحرم للطوارئ الذين
يستقبلون الحالات الطاريه هناك ايضا
الهلال الاحمر السعودي وعدد من الجهات
المساعده 30 نقطه اسعافيه متواجده في
ساحات الحرم المكي الشريف لتقديم الخدمه
الاسعافيه والانسانيه للزوار والمعتمرين
طبعا احنا نتكلم اليوم عن بدايه الخطه
التشغيليه الثانيه التي ستنتهي في نهايه
العشره الثانيه ثم بدايه الخطه الاكبر وهي
الخطه التشغيليه الثالثه التي تشمل العشر
الاواخر دعنا الان نذهب الى زميلنا
السلطان السلمي ايضا ليطلعنا على الاجواء
لديه وكيف هي الحركه كيفيه الحركه ايضا
هناك سلطان
اهلا بك ما يصلح بكافه مشاهدي قناه
العربيه بالفعل تعيش المدينه المنوره في
موسم العمره وموسم الحج اوضاع مختلفه
واشكال مختلفه لا سيما ان من يقصد المدينه
المنوره هم من المصلين والقادمين من مكه
المكرمه بعد انتهاء من مناسك العمره وكذلك
الزوار والمهتمين بالتاريخ الاسلامي
والمواقع الاثريه الاسلاميه نتوجه واجد
حاليا في المنطقه المركزيه المطله بشكل
مباشر على على
المسجد النبوي نتحدث انه الان تقام صلاه
القيام او التراويح ونتحدث انه هنالك
اعداد كبيره تدخل وتخرج من الحرم المكي
عبر مسارات خصصتها رئاسه الشؤون الحرمين
وهي كعمليه لاداره الحشود وضبط عمليات
التدفقات البشريه ايضا نتحدث انه وصل الى
المدينه المنوره وتحديدا دخل الى المسجد
النبوي نتحدث على قرابه 13 مليون زائر
ومصلي قاموا باداء الصلوات وزياره المسجد
النبوي منذ اول يوم رمضان وحتى يومنا هذا
نتحدث عن نسبه بلغت سبعه واربعين في المئه
زياده عن نفس هذا التوقيت في الموسم رمضان
الماضي نتحدث عن نسبه كبيره جدا لذلك عملت
رئاسه شؤون الحرمين والمسجد المسجد النبوي
على فتح المسجد النبوي بكامل السعه
الاستيعابيه وكذلك الاسطح وايضا كافه
الساحات المخصصه للصلوات وكذلك الزياره
فيما يتعلق بالمنطقه المركزيه هذه المنطقه
التي تسمى بالمركزيه من المدينه المنوره
الى العالم هي فكره مستحدثه وفكره جديده
بدات هذا الموسم وتحديدا وتحديدا مع بدايه
رمضان نتحدث عن وجود 18 مطبخا من ثمانيه
عشر دوله هنا يتم مراعاه كافه اذواق
الزائرين القادمين من مختلف انحاء العالم
لزياره المدينه المنوره والمسجد النبوي
لذكر شاهد كافه المطاعم التركيه والمطاعم
السعوديه وكذلك المطاعم الايطاليه
والهنديه والاندونيسيه المصريه وغيرها من
المطاعم التي تلقى رواجا كبيرا وتحديدا في
اوقات السحور او حتى اوقات الافطار نشاهد
اقبال الكبير لوجود هؤلاء المزدارين
والمصريين الخارجين الحرم المكي بشكل
مباشر لا بد المرور بهذه المنطقه المهيئه
والمجهزه بشكل كبير جدا
من المدينه المنوره مراسل العربيه كما
اشكر زميلنا اسامه القاسم وراسل العربيه
من مكه المكرمه
اقلعت اول طائره مطار اربيل الدولي الى
مدينه جده السعوديه عبر النقل الجوي
السعوديه فلينا بعد استئناف الرحلات بين
المدينتين نتابع
استولفت الرحلات الدوليه المنتظمه بين
السعوديه والعراق برحله قادمه من مطار
اربيل الى مطار الملك عبد العزيز بجده
وعلى متنها اكثر من 170 مسافر
الفرحه يعني واحد ما يقدر يوصف يعني
الفرحه جياشه والمشاعر جياشه يعني سعداء
جدا مسرورين واستقبلونا حتى بدايه المطار
يعني ما شاء الله عليهم رحبوا بنا وكذا
وقدمونا حتى هدايا نشكرهم والله نشكركم
جدا
[موسيقى]
سترتبط الرحلات الجويه المباشره والمنتظمه
بين جده واربيل بمعدل رحلتين اسبوعيا
وسيتم مضاعفه هذا العدد خلال الشهر المقبل
[موسيقى]
نجحت ولم نتخرجت ولا من رزقت باطفال ولا
من تزوجت ولا من صار عندي بيت ولا من صار
عندي مال وذهب ابد فالفرحه ما اعرف ما
اعرف اوصفها
نسيت اولادي وبقتي بس اريد اجي
[موسيقى]
استنافر رحلات الدوليه بين السعوديه
والعراق هو نتيجه للجهود المبذوله من مجلس
التنسيق السعودي العراقي والتي تهدف
لتعزيز العلاقات الاقتصاديه وتنميه
التبادل التجاريه بين البلدين
[موسيقى]
نهايه التاسعه هذا المساء نتذكر بالعناوين
ماكرون يحضر اوروبا من تجاهل الصين ويؤكد
على اهميتها الاقتصاديه للقاره العجوز
ادانه دوليه لعنف اسرائيل المتصاعد ضد
الفلسطينيين في القدس ودعواتنا لحكومه
نتنياهو بالتراجع والتهدئه
ترامب يكسب جوله قضائيه ضد ستورم دانييلز
ميكاليفورنيا ويتوعد المدعي العام في
روس مارفل يثير قلقا عالميا من تحوله الى
جائحه ودول تحذر مواطنيها من السفر الى
افريقيا
الى هنا تنتهي التاسع هذا المساء ولكن
اخبار العربيه دائما مستمره والان مع نشره
360 هذه الساعه الاخباريه مع الزميلين
راويه وطاهر اليكما ماذا لديكما اليوم
شكرا مساء الخير ميسون سنتحدث عن زياره
الرئيس الفرنسي اما ريال الى
الصين وكذلك الردود الفعل ايضا وايضا على
محاكمه ترامب التاريخيه وتيك توك دفاع
الصين عن ضد حضره في الخارج ولكن هي تحضره
اصلا في الداخل كوني معنا
[موسيقى]